[Musique]
au beau milieu du mozambique c'est un
jardin d'éden
le parc du goron gosa abrite une
biodiversité rares et des centaines
d'espèces sur 4000 kilomètres carrés
un écosystème unique devenu un lieu
d'étude privilégié qui attire
aujourd'hui des scientifiques du monde
entier
est un des meilleurs moyens pour étudier
la faune c'est de prendre de la hauteur
ok tout le monde est prêt dans cet
hélicoptère une équipe de spécialistes
de la préservation de la vie sauvage
se battant là ils se rendent dans le sud
du parc pour recenser des troupeaux
d'éléphants
quelques minutes suffisent à l'équipe
pour repérer les premiers animaux
laval solitaire oui il n'est pas marqué
il y en a d'autres et si il y en a deux
autres
certains pachydermes ont été équipées de
colliers gps
ce que les gardes forestiers veulent
vérifier c'est que la population
d'éléphants continue à croître il étudie
aussi leurs déplacements leurs habitudes
pour mieux les protéger
la population augmente nous avons près
de 1000 éléphants maintenant
nous sommes fiers car c'était notre
objectif et on y est parvenu
ça nous rend très heureux
[Musique]
la joie des anges gardiens des éléphants
est à la mesure de l'horreur qui a
frappé le parc il y à 45 ans
en 1977 la guerre civile éclate le
mozambique se déchirer le parc devient
un champ de bataille les animaux se
retrouvent au milieu des combats en 15
ans 95% de la faune disparaît
la guerre prend pas en 1992 et depuis la
vie est revenue dans le parc petit à
petit jusqu'à devenir aujourd'hui une
sorte de laboratoire de pointe à ciel
ouvert pour étudier les espèces du roi
de la savane jusqu'aux plus minuscule
animal
norina vincente est l'une des
conservatrices du parc dans ses armoires
elle répertorie tous les insectes et
reptiles présents ici
design spécial ce sont de nouvelles
espèces endémiques aux longues auront
gosa vous ne pouvez pas protéger ce
qu'on ne connaissait pas c'est pourquoi
donc la cie fiant systématiquement afin
de connaître toutes les espèces du parc
celles qui sont uniques et dont nous
devons particulièrement prendre son
temps
parmi les espèces étudiées par les
scientifiques certaines sont
particulièrement menacées comme le
pangolin
ses écailles sont très prisés du marché
asiatique pour leurs supposées valeur
médicinale
celui ci a été secouru la veille il
était aux mains de braconniers
on y va
affamés ils se précipitent sur les
termites
iam près dans des trains aux nourrices
bangolo je l'aide à manger car c'est la
première fois qu'on mène ici après des
jours et des jours de captivité aux des
braconniers
il doit se nourrir pour reprendre des
forces et qu'on puisse ensuite le
relâcher dans la nature
un travail de protection et de recherche
qui prend du temps et qui coûte cher
mais heureusement le parc a pu compter
sur une manne providentielle
ce soir là un homme est en train de
discuter avec quelques employés au bord
de l'eau
il s'agit de grecs car un milliardaire
américain
il a fait fortune dans les logiciels
informatiques
avant de tomber amoureux du gong aux as
et d'y investir massivement avec sa
fondation jusqu'à 3 millions d'euros par
an
comment pourrais-je mieux utiliser mon
argent qu'en protégeant cet écosystème
et en aidant parmi les gens les plus
pauvres au monde
qui ne voudrait pas dépensé tout son
argent comme ça
le parc fait aujourd'hui figure de
modèle en matière de préservation animal
prochaine étape réintroduire des
rhinocéros une des dernières espèces
manquantes les lions eux sont bien
présents leur nombre est passé de 10 à
200 ces vingt dernières années